what's up everybody walkman other things
you missed on gamespot from the kind of
funny dudes I'm Greg this is Tim and Tim
mm-hmm there's a new teenage mutant
ninja turtles game coming Paul one would
have known nobody ever would have known
about mutants in Manhattan never never
got league never done got leaked a lot
yeah I'll knew it was coming but it's
still exciting this year you're a huge
turtle thing oh yeah you're gonna walk
us through the trailer exactly so before
we even get into a crack I want you to
know that the achievement list likh diya
and screams leaks like so we're ever off
in this game for right time and from
that you can kind of garner a lot of
information what this okay so that once
you see this trailer you're like okay
let's get righted right good now here
you go it's t14 if you're younger than a
tee sign off right now activision we
knew that this is one of this was
rumored we knew that you knew the name
we must learn them that's okay okay not
nothing 22 crazy here but you know Ninja
Turtles obviously New York you get the
New York skyline and I don't think that
this is a direct homage but i think that
is definitely inspired by the original
cartoon theme song that starts off with
those oh yeah skyscrapers in the mood
you think what do you think they'll do a
new rendition of that uh probably not
seems like a different style yeah this
is definitely the art styles based off
of the i would say a mix between the
current ongoing TV show threw out in
2012 mixed with i mainly the idw comics
series what jascha if you are not
reading it is the best interpretation of
the turtles cobalt did you read when
they crossed over with batman with
Batman no I have that ready what about
when they crossed over the Ghostbusters
i read that i was at that's canon ok as
a Batman once as far as i know not can
ok within within the thing so here we
have more of New York right these orbs
up there you can see these orbs that are
kind of on the different roof in the
tops so from the achievement list we
know that there's an achievement based
on exploring the residential area ok so
to me that says that this it I don't
think it's an open world game but I
share there's gonna be hug where's there
a little bit more open than than we're
used to seeing from Platinum Games
licensed games so still farther done
Korra they've done transformers and
Korra not so well received transformers
well received right and I love that game
and it very much took the eighties
transformers car
brought to life in a video game and was
awesome now there's a lot of things that
make it seem like this game is bigger
than that game one of my biggest
critiques that game was that it was sure
there wasn't too much going on the fact
is the achievements there's 50 of them
in this game there was only 30 in corn
ok ready and transform ok who knows but
that that says to me bigger game so
maybe there is hub worlds sure and I
think that the green orbs are kind of
and there's also achievements for a mom
like rooftop running in like spark or
ask things so I think that those are
probably like ideal routes to go through
ok you're traversing the sea speaking of
routes dental care what there's dental
care sign over though oh god that right
is your TV career that was good too high
level dental joke here we obviously
happy as a foot the foot soldiers right
shredders dudes um this game is called
mutants in Manhattan right the everyone
thought when it first league that this
was gonna be kind of like a remake of
the Nationals 3 game that back in the
day called the Manhattan Project sure
does not not true at all so we see here
more foot soldiers doing the thing
that's got a classic subway shots right
obviously subways New York at all don't
you get there's some kind of interactive
behind there though with the trains
those are icons as if to get on the
train yeah not only to get our world put
a video game suggesting it's a bigger
world yeah the shooter Manhattan ease
yeah exactly instead looks like a super
soldier super floats over there was
another achievement that is to kill
bebop and Rocksteady with the train so
the Train can do damage now that's
illegal here we got rock steady himself
from hunt just right at a wreck shop
yeah oh my god this makes me giddy grand
so that's my question is like um you
know I my Turtles you know 89 I like me
I like the movie i like the animated
series i buy the toys i do all this
stuff yeah i mean to but i haven't kept
up since then this looks like a fun game
also game i wanna play definitely and
like I said the idw universe is by far
the best interesting followed up by the
current I'll go in 2012 shell so the
fact that this is kind of a mix of those
two yeah any very happy here you see a
shark fin now um hardcore Turtles people
know that this is our majin of court
either one of the the mighty mutanimals
you know him from if you're ridiculous
from the archie comics back in the day
um but you know he's also currently in
the 2012 show
he's made little pizzas here that he is
not yet in the idw comics so tonight the
Foot Clan father I'll take you back to
Rupert out there we got rivers peace
through pizzeria yeah everybody knows
that Rupert pizzerias wear
Michelangelo's boy woody works okay
that's from the idea of your comics okay
um pizza obviously Ninja Turtle of
plastic thing they love it there's also
achievements based on the pizza like
eating pizza so any pizza is a thing I
like to think I've got those in real
life yeah exactly there you go some
shredder shots beautiful more shredder
doesn't it look so cool yeah is that
what it looks like in the comic yep okay
yes miss it's very very much looks like
the comics some shots more than others
um where I say it's also infused to the
2012 because it has that kind of cge
look yeah this obviously classic turtle
shot on it didn't originate there but
the whole running of the rooftops and
gentleman from the moon the 2007 cg
movie I remember the whole trailer was
so awesome is a first shot really the
turtles uh looking great and I'm
positive we got April splinter yak so
this shots really interesting me because
this proves that it's not in the canon
of the comics Vaughn going ITW guys that
because April she looked like that month
back and in terms of serious yet and I
was a little haircut now that was a
different shirt on so it could still be
came and couldn't well the thing is so
in the comics there was a huge story
line about the gang warfare and there
was the savante and the purple dragon
and all that stuff that got wrapped up
and eventually we got to the the
mutanimals yeah sorry cool we have the
mutant ninja turtles what if there was
another gang right and ongoing villain
that was originally created for the
comics his old hobbies this cat and he's
really awesome he creates this gang of
mutant animals eat animals mutanimals
get it including pigeon Pete and mondo
gecko okay and a bunch of dudes um and
that story lines going on later when she
has your hair cut and all that stuff so
it's like it doesn't fit in cuz the news
in this okay and i love that the
mutanimals are getting so much love in
this in this game because we're seeing
was that we haven't even seen the comics
yet i'm assuming we're gonna see more of
them the admins talk about / and a wing
nut which is crazy we haven't seen him
for a long time so that's cool
inherently canutillo shot looking awful
metal go back a bit you got it don't
shot of all of them so this is the proof
that they're going after the idw style
cuz if you look at their bandanas don't
you have slightly different shapes like
Raphael's is more like a diamond looking
thing um that's based on artist Matias
Santa Luke oh okay he's had the longest
running on art run on the on doing
gotcha you got me kind of set the tone
for what they they look like I
personally love it I think it's really
cool and it gives them each kind of a
unique little little flair sure now
we're gonna get really getting great
shots which was here but then we get a
lot of all the focus of this bone you
see they go out to that first ball oh
yeah there you go so something is
interesting that I don't really like
about it yeah but this game is the fact
that their weapons like glow their color
mmm so the swords are the katana me like
yeah like you but it's because there's
so much actions right right right and
start seeing the gameplay here and now
instantly seeing this you're like I
PlatinumGames clearly why wait
transformers devastation you're like all
right I totally understand this I get
what's going on right there is just like
in transformers devastation there's
those like power attack moves now this
games also being directed by kenji Saito
we interview back at e3 right and he
talked to me about transformers
devastation how he wanted to make a game
that was like when you take your
transformers toys and bang them together
yeah and just play and this is obviously
that too is when you're playing with
your ninja turtle action figures go back
a bit sure that attack um I love here
that they're they're teaming up you know
Michelangelo's doing this thing and then
you see Leo and Raph kind of jump into
each other and do this like massive team
it's a all the shell connection you can
see that the gameplay is is very fast I
don't think a lot vast as a ninja
turtles was oh sorry transformers okay
but I think that it's a little more
hacking / e and I'm excited about this
because transformers to me felt really
really fast and slow and I think this
has more deliberate page I think that's
why
because you're gonna be going so quickly
around the world slashing things up you
got to keep it at a glance know where
your heads on what's to happen with them
you have the different colored foot
soldiers around there's one in purple
one in gray and I like a very classic
ninja turtle video game sure sure sure
sure sure sure we got some Raphael shots
the voices um I can identify them just
guys don on listening to sleep it's that
are here yeah so I'd be interested to
see who it is it doesn't sound like that
2012 show it ain't my boy rob paulsen
here we go we actually get the shot of
our majin there um he's a cyborg bounty
hunter shark of course why not as you do
so obviously PlatinumGames there's gonna
be boss fight yeah there's gonna be a
lot of them they're gonna be awesome
then we got this ridiculous jetpack
scene sure if you guys grew up with
Ninja Turtles you know that the toys are
just utterly insane hmm so why not give
them jetpack I agree they deserve him
and I think this is very much based off
the old school ninja turtle accessories
these robots I cannot identify I don't
think to my knowledge they've banned in
anything before obviously robots go back
forever I mean when little guys a little
announcer yeah the Baxter Stockman make
so these could be Stockman robots or
they could just be generic video game
bad guys we need somebody in this level
then have enough to get the hell creek
except this guy we definitely do know
he's one of the stone soldiers okay it
seems like he's more of a boss care to
but maybe not but maybe a mini boss or
maybe it's just like a UH intermediate
like not basic God but just a more
advanced dude he's one of krang's
Dimension X soldiers what we're seeing
with the turtles right as this looks to
be some kind of super-powered attack
right like you've built up a meter and
now you only get all of them in one
devastating i think it's the combo
techno I knew we do know from the
achievements that you can switch between
the turtles on the fly that's all I kind
of attack and do different things
together gotcha what we don't know is
whether or not there's co-op and I
really really really hope that there is
there were not in transformers
devastation um there's a gta4 kinda game
though exact you don't mean like your
the turtles you're a team you know uh
there's a achievement based on coop
moves but I don't know if they're just
sharing sure sure sure the other callers
your boy in one shot to my boy it's a
dialog Ron's then we got the social
stone soldier again different angle
mm-hmm more ass-kicking and that design
again straight out of a DW comments go
back a bit to the Cheryl doo-doo-doo-doo
doodly-doo you so earlier is trailer we
saw that they were fighting shredder up
here yeah shredder not one to use arrows
karai though huh karai one to use arrow
so I'm assuming she's in the game not
surprising that right there interesting
um my theory is that it's a kraang like
UFO thing because there was a one day in
the comics that Nate's not the idw
comics but in the other comics were
crying had a UFO that kind of cause
different status ailments okay so would
make them sleepy or make them confused
or make them like feel poisoned or we're
sure so that might be what we're seeing
here alright moisture other fights in
the bam rock steady now the reflexes he
has to bust out of a moving train and
perfectly hit them it's pretty pretty
I'm just saying those are impressive
reflexes there's yeah is do the
achievements in Ted V Pape well that's
Rossi I know we see be back in a second
Oh haven't seen this trailer a few days
yeah hey there you guys with this
chainsaw which is this is literally
scene right out of the iw idw comics
which I cannot recommend enough go Rio
again I'm apparent now they're they're
so so good this game looks awesome I'm
really excited to hear more about it I
mean this is nestor this seems like that
with a perfect fit i know when a while
back people had been up oh maybe
Rocksteady's name's gonna be ninja
turtles and that sounds cool tudo get me
wrong but in terms of just a fast-paced
action games i wanna jump around like
what platinum does best like this
transformers devastation right I'm
really happy they didn't go with the the
80s cartoon turtles because although
everyone remembers them fondly like
that's a much goofier vibe and that's
not that's not what you want from Ninja
Turtles is what you want okay x gonna
give it to you ladies and gentlemen what
else well I mean Activision platinum Rex
Crossing okay activision platinum x see
what i do them yeah i'll ease gentlemen
what do you think of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles mutants in Manhattan let
us know in the comments share the video
with your friends and of course keep
coming back to gamespot for more of this
cross kind of funny content